it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week gives you the opportunity
to do one thing and one thing only
killing Nazis not just any Nazis robot
Nazi use and thereafter our bridges
Wolfenstein the new order is out on all
the platforms that Nazis heat and this
is your chance to join the resistance
and take down your robot enemy anyway
you want to wake up your dad sleep with
one eye open May twentieth but don't get
too worked up relax grab a mojito build
a tropical paradise with tropico 5 it's
got an insanely detailed world that you
can rule the way you choose to there's
really no wrong way to be El Presidente
unless your people starve and you're
ravaged by natural disasters and war but
that's just one of the pressures at
being a super awesome El Presidente
comes will let the meat cake March 23rd
also this week and absolutely stunning
and beautiful game comes to Oh God you
got a flower in your eye didn't anyone
tell you in your eye huh drakengard 3
pits players against hordes of fiends
and foes in remorseless hack and slash
combat but don't forget to harness the
power of your dragon which allows you to
charge by trample your foes and even
demolish buildings become the dragon
whisperer mate wyeth van Helsing is back
this week with even more amazing
adventures so many adventures in fact
that it required a sequel the popular
monster hunter returns to save the day
again with the help of his cheeky
companion lady Katarina let's just hope
they keep all of her awesome one-liners
no greetings for me where are your
manners the adventure begins May twenty
second and last but clearly not least
supergiant returns with another stunning
title that seems to leave the world
again impressed with this visual and
audio style not to mention one of the
most badass lady characters in some time
we're all pretty hyped so let's hurry up
and get here may twentieth for further
details visit gamespot's new releases
page release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
see you next week